[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you follow ball
[Music]
this is how you make it in this country
[Music]
[Music]
freeze jump in front of them it's so
hard to love you sometime still by
[Music]
[Music]
crazy ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Toby how do we do well that was better
yep ah captain you're at my desk just
what I want to see first thing in the
morning you're three minutes late
Peralta not my fault
I had a plumbing problem which reminds
me I'm gonna need a new departmentally
issued phone come on really I'm a few
minutes late so you're gonna call me out
in front of everyone
good idea everyone gather round so I can
call out Peralta in front of you okay
fine I was three minutes late I'm sorry
for doing one thing wrong oh it's more
than one thing let's start with the
Chris Taub murder there's an amazing
solve I got him to confess in 20 minutes
you also mislabeled the evidence so that
confession is worthless if the sergeant
hadn't caught your mistake here are
three cases with sloppy paperwork here
are two pictures one is your locker the
other is a garbage dump in the
Philippines can you tell which is which
that one's the down they're both your
locker I should've guessed that it's
good this folder is labeled undies comma
dirty so I won't confuse it with undies
comma clean also who cares about all
these rules I have more felony arrests
than any other detective here you also
have more mice living in your desk and
then any other detective Algernon
you guys Algernon's back get rid of the
mouse and get your act together
now what's going on here my neighbor's
dog had a litter they're looking for
people to adopt I wish he had tiny puppy
shoes I would totally shine his little
shoes for free oh dude say the cutest
stuff look I love a good dog as much as
the next guy but this building doesn't
allow animals Andy take him outside
what and shoot him no just keep him
outside oh come on Ron I'm just a little
puppy I ain't doing nothing wrong I'm
just a puppy
oh I like your mustache I wish I could
have one but I can't the domination
little burbly
hmm-hmm-hmm
okay take him out and shoot this is
parkour internet sensation of 2004 and
it was in Milan the Bond films it's
pretty impressive the goal is to get
from point A to point B as creatively as
possible so technically they are doing
parkour as long as the point a is
delusion and point B is okay we all go
together or we go one at a time here it
is here it is truck two refrigerators
two dumpster 360 spin on to the palace
backflip gainer into the trash hardcore
parkour
hello it's with the cast I sprained my
wrist oh no what happened don't worry
about it I'm fine yeah geez Amy back off
leave the guy alone all right huddle up
everybody bring it in bring it so he
wouldn't say what happened which can
only mean one thing he's in a Fight Club
no he did it doing something he's
embarrassed by like smiling only
question is how do you hurt your arm
smiling could be a sports injury I
sprained my wrist in college playing
field hockey
Bin's field hockey yeah it's much more
violent than the women's game we're not
allowed to wear anything that protects
our breasts attention everyone I can
hear you speculating about the nature
and origin of my injury from my office I
tripped over an uneven sidewalk I did
not think it was relevant to your jobs
the jobs which you should all be doing
right now get to work
do you want to know how I actually heard
- yes
I was looking Kevin and I attend a class
for fitness and for fun oh my god I've
mastered all the moves the pizza toss
the tornado the Scorpion the oopsie
doodle why are you telling me this
because no one will ever believe you no
son of a [ __ ]
so we've been called out to this hiking
trail because there's some reports that
some teenagers are digging bags of dog
poop out of the trash and having dog
food fights I don't believe it
oh my god it's real yeah I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna go deal with this I'm
leaving hey hey hello boys I am Leslie
Knope I work for the Department of ok
[Music]
this is a little fun this is fun for you
and you and you
what are they these madam are STDs what
are you talking about buddy STDs save
the dates for Vivian on my wedding
ah yes hey just out of curiosity how
many people have you given STDs - Lots
like a hundred what's going on oh okay I
get it
STD has another meaning you're gross no
one else is gonna think that everyone is
going to think that but it's sweet that
your mind didn't go there thank you
it is kind of sweet well your first
dance beats you you give me fever will
you be seven crabs as the reception the
other B's guys this is my wedding this
is important to me no more jokes you're
right and we're sorry yeah we love you
buddy
warts and all sorry I made a rash
decision I was hitching to say it okay
I'm done I have an STD
so just RSVP yeah the number
you